the Republican presidential candidate
Jeb Bush he's got some big fans and they
work on Wall Street and Betty Lewis here
to explain Betty so this is about
campaign donations that's right it is at
Wall Street and perhaps one of the most
unsurprising developments right and we
know this that Wall Street heads back to
Republican candidates time and time
again so Jeb Bush is on the top of the
list it looks like Goldman Sachs their
bankers have donated something like 144
thousand dollars in total so far to the
Jeb Bush campaign and they range in
people from the co-heads of investment
banking and a submit or investment
management Robert Zoellick who is one of
their advisors of course the former head
of the World Bank so in a Goldman Sachs
JP Morgan Morgan Stanley all of those
all of those banks have supported or are
supporting the Republican contenders
about the bank's the individual the
individuals exercise their right I think
it's a 2700 dollar limit I believe it's
2200 but yeah to 2200 um you're correct
the individual so what do the banks want
though pin right so what are the one of
the hot button issues that they want
going into the 2016 elections will one
of them that could be a bipartisan issue
is to roll back the shadow banking
industry okay so we're talking about you
know the peer-to-peer lenders right
we're talking about private equity
groups you know Henry Kravis might he be
targeted in all those firms who are
doing what banks traditionally did
before dodd-frank might that be that an
issue that both sides at both Clinton
the lino Clinton or Bernie I don't know
about Bernie Sanders let's say Clinton
or bush or others that the Democrats and
Vulcans might agree on so that could be
one issue for the banks all right well
done thanks for bringing it to our
attention